when you're addressing your brother's
crimes do you think anyone had any idea
that he was living a lie was there
something in you that was like this just
doesn't seem right I can't say like oh I
knew something was off like I wasn't
close with him for many years so I can't
say like oh I saw this coming because I
don't think anybody did if you were to
talk to him what would you say
well I think that
um I will say this is it's so tough to
speak about
and my heart really breaks for the
victims and their families but my prayer
for my brother is that he will repent
and truly be broken over his son have
you forgiven him
for his sins I think
by the grace of God I can say that I
have forgiven him and at the same time
forgiveness and trust are two different
things I'm grateful that he is in that
place that Justice is being served and I
think that that is the best way that I
can love at this point Josh is currently
serving more than 12 years in a Texas
Federal Prison after being sentenced on
charges of child pornography last May
Ginger told me she hasn't spoken to him
in two years but supports Josh's wife
Anna and their seven children I'm always
there I'm always here for them if and
when they need help or want to talk I'm
always here I hope that they would know
that allegations of Josh's past sexual
abuse first surfaced in 2015. according
to a police report a then 14 year old
Josh fondled five underaged girls
including four of his sisters parents
Jim Bob and Michelle were criticized for
downplaying the assaults after it became
public he was a boy young boy in puberty
and a little too curious about girls
TLC canceled 19 Kids and Counting
shortly after were you ever a victim of
his so many things have been
um difficult to like
discuss and so yeah that's not really
something I'm comfortable talking about
in Ginger's candid new Memoir becoming
free indeed the 29 year old does get
very candid about her decision to leave
her family's devout Christian religious
sect known as The Institute in basic
life principles hopefully their lives
are being directed in the direction of
loving God and I have a Ministry mindset
the church was led by disgraced Minister
Bill Gothard who stepped down in 2014
after more than 30 women accused him of
harassment and molestation in his
statement Gothard denied any immorality
you said writing this book was the
hardest thing that you've ever done
you've lived a life Ginger what was the
most difficult part
for you what I grew up in was very
fear-based based on Superstition
manipulation control and so my view of
God was warped I was promised that if I
followed these teachings from Phil
Gothard this man that my life would be a
success and God would bless me but if I
didn't follow every principle maybe
God's going to kill me in an accident
I'm not sure do you look at the
teachings as a cult or like you're being
indoctrinated
I would say that
um
it was definitely cult-like I can't say
oh it was a cult I'll leave that to the
experts but there were so many things
that
um made me think okay this this reminds
me of
um something that's cult-like because
it's so hard to leave that community at
times if you violate at any point one of
these principles then that's when
disaster will come upon you my little
four-year-old Felicity she has so cute
her artwork is this mommy daddy here yes
and Eddie Joe
um and then I don't know what that is
that's not another child I was gonna say
is it a doll I hope it's a dog Ginger
showed me around her La home and
illustrating just how far the former
reality star has come she read from a
journal entry written just over seven
years ago this was from September 18
2015.
um last night I had a good talk with one
of my parents the Lord has been
convicting me about modesty a few times
I had on a borderline kneeling skirt
that would come above my knee when
sitting God brought conviction into my
heart in this area so I asked for help
in accountability I wrote that you know
probably late in the evening sitting
there thinking oh no why did I wear a
skirt that would come here when sitting
down as opposed to like an inch longer
so that's it it was all outward rules
based and I thought either God's pleased
with me right now because I'm doing this
or he's not
um and so that's just how I lived my
entire life
after ultimately walked away from that
way of life in 2017 with the support of
her husband of six years Jeremy when
Jeremy came on the scene we had to
listen to 60 plus hours of Bill
gothard's teaching before we could
really start talking or go further in
our relationship and that was actually
really helpful he said well look at what
he just said and look at what God's word
says and he didn't grow up in this
teaching and that was so helpful because
that started me on the Journey of
examining the word of God for myself
instead of taking one person's opinion
you said that you wished looking back
that that you and Jeremy could have had
a different type of courtship but
despite it all you would still choose
him oh my goodness every day I would
choose Jeremy he is the best thing
that's happening he is so much fun he
keeps me laughing all the time he also
has just walked alongside me throughout
this journey and it's not been easy for
him I'm sure
coming into this with all the
difficulties I've had to walk through
there have been really hard days so he's
he's been my number one supporter
thinking about that makes you emotional
he does because he's just so sweet he's
so sweet
what was your biggest fear when you said
um okay now I have to tell my family I
you know
what was your biggest fear then
yeah I think you never know what kind of
reactions you're going to get whenever
um anyone has a conversation with family
about anything but I sought to from the
very beginning share with my parents
what I had changed on and why I saw this
as something that was important to
change on so whether I was wearing pants
I remember that conversation that I had
with them and I wanted to say I don't
see this in the word of God and then
whenever I was writing this book I was
very clear
um that it's not a tell-all about my
family I love my family I'm so thankful
for how they sacrifice so much for me
um so this story though is my faith
journey and I feel a responsibility to
as well because I promoted those
teachings so that's what I shared with
my family what was the response that you
got I think that you know it's
interesting different ones of them are
still in that setting so some were more
excited for me to share this story while
Others May still agree to disagree is
there an agreed to disagree or is there
right and wrong
I think that in this setting it is said
that there's a very black and white way
to do life but at the end of the day I
do believe that those in the system
really want what's best for me and so
it's like they're living their lives and
I'm loving them and the same that they
would do for me do you think your
parents are going to read the book
I think so yeah I've I've talked with
them and I think that they are I think
that they want to hear even from my
perspective
um my story and so I'm sure that they
will read it do you worry about losing
their support
I think that I've been growing up in the
public eye and so I know that even
speaking publicly that can be twisted in
headlines it can it can get you know
messed up and so I don't ever want that
to come back negative on my family but
ultimately like I look at that all of
those years that they poured into me and
sought to give me their best you know
that they thought was good for me had
the best intentions because they were
promised that this would bring their
kids success I saw that that was their
heart all along and they really were
loving and faithful parents
now with her Newfound Freedom Ginger
will be raising her own daughter's
four-year-old Felicity and two-year-old
Evangeline far away from the public eye
I was raised on TV since I was a you
know at the age of 10. and
um I see that and I've had a lot of
opportunities come a few because of it
and at the same time there are
difficulties being in that we wanted to
give our girls the opportunity to choose
if they choose to be in the public eye
that's great we'll support them with
whatever they want to do but while
they're so young we're just keeping
their keeping their faces off the camera
[Music]
foreign